ils ont le sentiment d'avoir été
abandonné par les forces de l'ordre et
compte bien exprimé leur colère des
habitants du quartier des grésillés de
chenôve appel à se rassembler samedi à
dijon
un rassemblement qui se veut pacifique
pour demander la démission du préfet
aujourd'hui si on se rassemble 6 pour
aller à la préfecture demander des
comptes au préfet qu'il rende des
comptes sur cette action de
d'autorisation ou de non-action de la
police pourquoi est ce qui l'a empêché
la police de faire son travail
j'attends qu'on nous donne des de nos
droits notre droit à la paix que le
droit à la sécurité
notre droit la protection on n'a aucun
droit les arrestations aujourd'hui de
plusieurs membres de la communauté de
tchétchènes n'ont rien changé à leur
détermination dans le quartier des
grésillés
si certains habitants ont bien
l'intention de participer à ce
rassemblement
d'autres sont plus réticents bien sûr on
va manifester
qu'est ce qu'elle arrive et on va dire
ces trois joueurs qui sont passés on a
trouvé ça c'est pas normal parce que des
gens qui habitent ici y'a pas que il
n'ya pas que nous qu'on est là il ya des
vieux et des gamins des mers et appelons
truc mais on va le préfet qui voulait
pas intervenir on ne sait pas pourquoi
bah écoutez moi le plus important c'est
que le calme est revenu c'est le plus
important et plus apaisé donc pour moi
c'est l'essentiel
de son côté le collectif des habitants
des grésillés explique sur les réseaux
sociaux qu'il se désolidarise du
rassemblement prévu estimant que ça
n'est pas le bon moment pour une telle
action
quant à la préfecture elle nous indique
ne vouloir faire aucun commentaire sur
le sujet